taking a photograph used to be a process
composing a shot developing the film
printing it but for most of us they're
all but instant now thanks to
smartphones we have high end cameras in
our pockets at all times selfies - snaps
- Phoenix we're taking a ton of pictures
last year alone is estimated that humans
took an astonishing 1.2 million
autographs so is all this photography
changing how we see the world and
ourselves to find out we use special eye
tracking software try to find out why my
selfies don't quite look right and spoke
with researchers at the forefront of
photo psychology all to figure out just
how photography is affecting us let's
start with perhaps the most
controversial form of modern photography
that that's a manga I think this guy's
the beloved and dreaded selfie I don't
really post selfies on social media I
guess it's a little like I don't know
it's like it's kind of competing but I
know I don't sense people that take
selfies but I don't personally taking
selfies is different from other photos
with regular pics you look at the scene
and think about how the picture looks
with selfies we're usually focused on
how we look not bad then you save it and
then you try again maybe try a different
filter there's a lot of pressure to make
sure you get the right angle and the
right lighting and everything so it's
actually a lot more work than it seems
I think selfies are sometimes like a
representation of what you want to look
like they like the best version of you
mm-hmm there we go good now when I take
a selfie which granted isn't that often
it never looks quite right to me do the
up thing people like the up thing that's
why there are so many filters and
touch-up apps out there so that people
can get what they post to be a little
bit closer for what they see in their
minds I so phase 2 2 is the sequel to
what's clearly one of the most popular
touch-up apps out there you can do all
sorts of things with it you can thin or
broaden your nose you can change the
size of your mouth you can smooth out
wrinkles and blemishes and imperfections
smooth out some of that on that wrinkle
action what else can I do here I'm going
to try to see how it changes my existing
selfie to make it more seductive oh it's
definitely plumping my lips whoo oh no
all right let's take that back to
natural I refuse to subscribe to these
Beauty ideals but even without filters
why do selfies look off in the first
place
selfies are not what you actually look
like I think they're making us more
self-critical borås pass cover is a
facial plastic and reconstructive
surgeon in new jersey a few years ago he
started noticing a troubling pattern
with his patients they would take out
their phone out of their bag and say hey
Doc look how big my nose looks it would
show me on their phone and the phone was
destroyed it to some degree right the
portions were off to find out just how
off he teamed up with researchers at
Rutgers New Jersey Medical School and
Stanford to develop a mathematical model
that could measure that Distortion what
it showed was that if you were to
compare a photo take it from 12 inches
one foot approximate selfie range to a
portrait taken about five feet the
selfie
makes the nasal base appear
approximately 30% larger that's right if
you're taking a selfie with the phone
about a foot away then your nose will
appear about 30% wider than if the photo
was taken by someone standing around
five feet away from you one of his
fellow researchers even designed a
program to reverse the effects of taking
a close-range photo so I'm about to
upload a selfie I just took and we'll
see what the program is able to do to
reverse that effect so you can see in
the photo that there is some distortion
in kind of the size of my nose
and if we start to move the camera back
my face starts to flatten so if that
little bit of fisheye effect does go
away so that is what my nose really
looks like dr. Pascal would tell me if I
went into his office seeking rhinoplasty
because of Instagram anxiety so even
without filters the distance and yes the
angle of your selfie can distort how you
look but how do taking and posting
selfies make us feel the research is
still very much in the early stages but
one study out of York University that
looks specifically at college aged women
showed that subjects taking selfies felt
worse than subjects who didn't they were
more anxious less confident and felt
less physically attractive in comparison
to the group that didn't take in post
selfies so what happens to us when we
point the camera at something other than
ourselves taking photos has both
positive and negative effects on
people's experiences and memories this
is Alexandra Parrish a marketing
professor at NYU
she says taking pictures can negatively
impact your memory of experiences that
aren't primarily visual like concerts or
grabbing a bite to eat its point it's
really detract from your ability to hear
the music to taste the food to its
fullest and what about doing it for the
gram do we still enjoy our experiences
when we plan to share photos of them on
social media turns out not so much
instead of staying focused on what we're
photographing we start getting
distracted by what others might think we
call this self presentational concern or
anxiety and and this is actually what we
find can take people out of the moments
make them enjoy the experience less are
there any kind of best practices for
people who want to take photos want to
accentuate their enjoyment of things and
even want to share them but kind of want
to maximize the good and and minimize
the bad I'm not a proponent of avoiding
sharing at all costs I think that the
key thing to do is to take photos for
yourself in the moment and then to
separate the sharing part of the process
to actually have the sharing happen
later on but there are some positive
effects to the act of photo taking
itself can really draw people into annex
Ariane's make them more immersed or
engaged and that's going to have
positive effects on people's enjoyment
embarrasses research shows you don't
even have to actually take the photo to
reap these benefits just the intent is
enough when it's more of an
observational type of experience that's
where we see the positive effects of
photo taking because you're capturing
the scene in a different way you're
forced to focus on specific details okay
so we know that being in the moment
while taking photos has its benefits but
how does that translate to the real
world to find out we met up with Chris
Burkhardt a professional known for
photos of spectacular landscapes and
extreme sports when I'm composing an
image it's as much about what you're not
including is what you are including we
wanted to see how taking pictures for a
living might change the way he looks at
the world so we've reached out to tobe a
Swedish company that makes specialized
glasses that track the wearer's eye
movements when you focus your eyes in a
particular spot it follows your
movements and traces a path so we met up
at the Exploratorium Science Museum in
San Francisco that's filled with
Instagram friendly exhibits if you've
seen my Instagram you know I'm very much
not a photographer however we are both
going to use Toby's eye tracking
software and capabilities to see how
Chris looks at the world when he walks
around the Exploratorium taking pictures
and I look at the world it's amazing
[Music]
so what's your turn my turn your the
subject now all right I feel because
what my eyes are doing is being recorded
I feel under a degree of scrutiny that
is a little intimidating that actually
looks kind of cool
[Music]
next we headed to Wired's office to try
another test we wanted to see how the
pros look at photos and whether they
sweat the details more than amateurs so
Chris and I looked at a bunch of
different images including his own way
to evaluate the quality of the images
and as we did tobey's eye tracking
software followed our points of interest
this iconic Dorothea Lange portrait
probably showed the biggest difference
and how Chris and I look at photographs
I'm more like just kind of looking at
certain less points longer periods of
time basically Chris got more out of the
time he spent with the photo than I did
here's a heat map showing what our eyes
focused on this one's mine I mostly
looked at the mothers face but see all
those light green areas my eyes were all
over the place
Chris on the other hand had fewer points
of interest but he was more focused
looking at the way the mothers hand
rests on her chin the child's hand
beside her picking out the specific
details in the image that make it so
powerful we also reviewed results from
the field test at the Exploratorium
comparing how Chris and I approached
this tree trunk I don't want to just
walk right up to the first thing I see
in start taking picture because what if
the back side is better so I walked
almost all the way around the tree
exhibit first I just want to make sure
before I take the camera out because the
moment that I pull the camera up I know
that I'm gonna be looking at things
differently when the camera comes up
with a phone comes out then all the
sudden it's like okay now I'm thinking
about composing the image as opposed to
just looking at it and seeing what my
eye or my nose or my hand isn't actually
drawn to this is Peter's video it seems
like when you are trying to pick an
image or pick a subject you're
experiencing it through the lens of your
phone I'm hoping to look into something
more as you've found something and then
found the best way to capture it so in
both the field and screen tests Chris
approached photos more deliberately than
I did seemed like his technical
expertise allowed him to cut out clutter
and focus better on specific details
so whatever you learned about how
photography affects us well for one
thing sofie's can distort the way we
look
but taking photos can actually improve
our moves help us remember experiences
better and make us feel more engaged in
the moment as long as we're snapping
pics of things like landscapes and not
interrupting activities that require a
full attention so maybe think about that
the next time you pull out your phone at
a concert and besides conventional
wisdom is Right focusing on how many
likes we're gonna get on Instagram makes
us feel worse whether the cameras
pointed at ourselves or at the world
around us so as good as I look in this
shot maybe I'll try keeping it to myself